yeah it sounds like going it's Justine
and today I am so excited because in my
hand as you can see I have the new
iPhone 10 and we are going to now test
out some photos and some video one of
the things that I'm most excited about
as I mentioned in my iPhone
8 camera test video this does 1080p 240
frames a second and it looks absolutely
incredible
I have a lot of high-end cameras they
can't even do that so this little thing
is changing everything so let's go test
it out I got Jenna over there she's
there a sweat pan my first touch get on
her okay Jack is like an iPhone
photographer
[Music]
stop moving okay okay do one phone I'm
actually impressed good it's like that
one yeah look at that look very nice oh
just a little bit so the problem is if
you just have split in because let me
take a couple more oh oh oh it's not an
iPhone problem it's like it's a big
problem
yeah let's do a jump boiler alert that's
how we get the shot so much like the
portrait mode that a lot of you guys are
used to on the old iPhone you can now do
that on the front-facing camera
so there's Jenna and now when I go into
it I hit edit this will give you a good
example of what it looks like so here's
portrait that's the front-facing selfie
mode you can also use the portrait
lighting features exactly like you would
in the normal rear camera portrait mode
you can change it from the natural
lights a studio light contour light
stage light and the stage light mono so
right now this is a test of the
front-facing video this is just a test I
wish that I had something more exciting
to say or do hey Jenna hey whoa wait hi
Nick hi
wait hello we're uh we're just the park
and I'm jumping and I'm dancing and I'm
having a wonderful time
[Music]
so probably my least favorite things is
changing from different camera settings
because you actually have to go into the
camera settings so here we are we're
gonna change the slow mode to 120 and
then I'm gonna change the regular to 30
for the second
[Music]
she warned that's my angel hello let's
see some dog action
I'll see what it looks like when we zoom
in come on dogs
give me some action hi Manny
who's a good boy
[Music]
so my dog is not really kind of children
and there's a very tiny child here super
tiny he's being a good boy though now
we've done a video test let's try out
some photos one of the things I love the
most about the new phone one of things
that I love about the new iPhone 10
station lets it out we're at a dog park
yeah this one looks so good
smile oh my gosh that's great oh that's
a nice Apple look there we go man good
boy let me get this shot oh gosh that's
disgusting portrait mode to Maddy who's
a good boy there you are who's a good
boy
wait look here
Maddy thick wait what this right here
good boy here you go take a stick
bribery oh gosh
that was almost the first fall if it
look
[Music]
so yesterday we were filming a bunch
with the iPhone 10 and today we are back
here outside getting some more really
great shots for you and I'm so much
happier with how the photos are turning
out today because we have much more
light the Sun is about to go down but
now we're gonna take a few more portrait
shots I'm ready for my close-up Nick
should I move are you doing okay good
[Music]
so this did a really good job the color
looks incredible this is a good shot
this is something I'm gonna send home to
moms and say mom thinking of you these
look a lot better than the ones I took
yesterday so here's one of Nick who is
behind the camera right now studio light
contour look at that stage light it did
such a good job
I'm impressed it does such a great job
of pulling out highlights and so much
color in the background I'm pretty
impressed with HDR to be honest with you
you can have the option to just save HDR
photos or save the original I have it
turned on so that I can save both the
HDR photos look so great that there
really is no need to even have over them
on you our main focus on you okay so
we're doing another back facing camera
test here it is
there is crying children here I think
it's crying I'm not sure I'm not sure
this'll look cooler in slow-mo
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I'm dizzy the zoom lens also has
optical image stabilization so not only
just this help with your portrait mode
photos but this will help with she's
trying to reset her Apple ID password I
feel bad cuz I can hear her in the
background so obviously we've already
talked about this but on the new iPhone
10 it has dual cameras much like the
iPhone 7 but it is now placed in this
beautiful vertical fashion there is the
new quad tone flash in the center so
this helps kind of even out all of the
photos when you're using a flash which I
haven't even tried yet so let's try the
flash
[Music]
I've looked better at least the picture
quality was good
I'm blind okay let's see how it looks I
think it looks it looks fine it's fine
it doesn't look bad doesn't look amazing
it just looks fine I tried the
front-facing flash see what that looks
like
I don't like flash I hate take me go to
the flash on I'd never turn it on the
only time I turn it on is what it's
accidentally turned on one of the things
I'm really excited about trying out it's
low light with the new iPhone 10 there's
also an option when you put on the live
photo which usually always turns on or
like why are you turning on you try them
crazy but there's a lot of great new
features like loop bounce and long
exposure that utilizes a live photo so
maybe you might want to keep it on one
of the things I do like about the zoom
lens it does have optical image
stabilization whereas previous version
did not so yeah to me and you don't even
know what I'm saying anymore all right
let's get out of here
[Music]
you